if you can find an eye cream that
actually has that peachy pigment i like
to dab it on
and then what i'll do is
i'll wear this out
instead of concealer i will go around
with this eye cream on
and do you see
the dark circle has disappeared
at least i would say
60 70
now i don't recommend putting makeup on
top of eye creams it can curdle like
cream in a hot tomato sauce and you
don't want that so
this on its own not only acts as a
concealer brightening and lightening the
effect and look of a dark circle
but it's also taming the dark circle
while you're wearing it it's
sort of a perfect alchemy of skin care
as makeup
and i
love this it's my tried and true
run out grab one experiment with it and
tell me what you think
i want to talk today about corrective
beauty makeup
so i'm going to take our onyx
eyeliner from flower beauty
and as you can see one eye is just lower
than the other so this eye is more open
and this one is more closed so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to put this
on the upper water line and it's going
to open my eye to match this one check
it out
so not in even the lash line only the
upper waterline
[Music]
pretty amazing right
let's see after i put some mascara on
for the final look i'm done now and i
feel like my eyes look much more even
than they did before
corrective eye makeup inner water line
on the eye that's more closed
i have five minutes to do my makeup
ready
okay
the supernova celestial timing width
yes please i'm going to even out my skin
tone give it a lavender hue which
lavender and beige are not only a
gorgeous design color combination
but it's actually going to even out my
skin underneath
celestial priming whip done moisturizer
on the lip
i'm going to use the new hollywood
secret
get real
foundation serum
don't forget to go up on the ears and
into the hairline
because none of us want to be that 16
year old with a giant baseline
also do yourself a favor wash your hands
i'm going to just demonstrate and
watch if i didn't wash my hands
afterwards
this is what happens the final touch
i want to lock it in
spray powder
just in the oily tea so i can be doing
everywhere else
[Music]
you